[Music]
and Coco nutty news sounds crazy
submitted by Bart in an accident what
the hell is under the it don't like the
stick so typical racist one I know a guy
shared a disgusting story about him
having sex with a coconut and people are
trying it out that sounds terrible
that's like [ __ ] your dick with a
razor blade I should [ __ ] run a
broken up echo coin is very rough
[Music]
I mean I can understand cantaloupe
watermelon maybe some mango if it's
really big
this is concur published but a coconut
give you some dot I know that's a hairy
ass one those things are rough well
daddy drill a hole in one like you have
to make a perfect and it's hollow on the
inside there's no friction you're not
hitting anything that's like [ __ ] a
two-by-four it's like drilling through
wood and then your [ __ ] that piece of
wood thank you guys that that's what
[ __ ] an [ __ ] like okay hold on no
like it's only pirate on the ring yeah
yeah it's just a ring that's like what's
the point it's not like a bagina words
like a smash it's like a weave there's
no friction all the way through yeah
yeah the vagina is a holster yeah right
so this was posted on reddit and a
subreddit called today I [ __ ] up this
today I [ __ ] up then happen to Dave so
quite a few years back for obvious
reasons I'm using a throwaway account as
my family knows my main reddit user name
and his user name is coconut throwaway
69 anyway around eight years back I
lived in northern Mozambique a coastal
southern african country with quite a
warm climate my mother at the time was
going through different moment yes mom
is a new mom now yeah my mother at the
time it'll be he knows how that phrase
works
he keeps entering it so look at you and
Alan why are you looking at me I feel
like I'm catching you trying to feed my
mother at the time was going through a
health nut phase and only buying foods
she deemed healthy enough one of these
was coconuts
she would buy several coconuts a week to
use in food from the local market one
day I heard that my mom was going to be
out for pretty much the entire afternoon
horny me decides that it would be a
fantastic idea to [ __ ] a coconut
honestly till this day I can't fathom
why I thought that would be a good idea
but my train of thought back then
somewhat clearly caught how old is this
person at this time they'll mention
that's because there's a phase when you
stick it digging everything like in the
movie American Pie yes rounder guys on
dubs are just scientists okay we like to
experiment with everything we're
exploring and discovering pocket and
experiment is not the same thing
no [ __ ] is the experiment what's
handy cotton like yeah you want to [ __ ]
couch you want to do this you want to do
that you just want to like explore and
see like you're an explorer not a
scientist bro I'm sorry I have read your
data like don't you care about your dick
the head was perfectly fine but you
don't know that unless you experiment
you have your control subject which is
your baseline but then you have to try
other things to see what might be more
sensation you might know what you want
to do idea you must emit look at that
focus on Johnny continue to plot against
disgusting no I end up grabbing the
coconut drill and through 20 minutes of
efforts I end up creating a hole large
enough for me to stick my porker into
okay I decide it requires some Lube and
grabbed the nearest slippery thing
parentheses some butter before shoving
it into the coconut followed shortly by
my meat I [ __ ] the coconut and
actually feels pretty damn good
so I blow my load shove the coconut
under my bed and continue about my day
why not throw it away [ __ ] know how
much work it took 20 minutes just a
trophy for the next week the coconut is
my Saviour whenever I want to get off I
simply take it out and [ __ ] it and it's
the lively Pike hole made better each
time by my accumulating volumes of my
semen and butter acting as a loop I need
to see the blueprints of God blue put
Michigan get moldy reels on about a week
and a bit after the initial coconut [ __ ]
I had been using it pretty much every
day since I began to notice a few more
slides than usual as well as a not
unpleasant smell about my room of course
it must be the coconut right so I
decided that I'll [ __ ] it once more
before I throw it out and get a new one
worst mistake I ever made
maggots you see the reason for the
increased number of flies is that the
coconut was evidently in hindsight a
nearly perfect place to lay eggs as I
penetrate the coconut one last time I
begin to feel this strange wriggling
sensation which I fell in love with
puzzled I pull my [ __ ] out to discover
that it is covered in rotten and moldy
butter and semen and teeming with tiny
[ __ ] maggot they were wriggling all
over my big head and somewhere you've
been trying to force their way up my
ears
watch me here's the grossest part about
it you came inside it and you left it in
there the most disgusting [ __ ] person
on earth I hope no women ever touch a
dick evidence disc hold on so thanks for
e all many more men wanted to try it out
what and saw they end up doing a lot of
T is you today I [ __ ] up with their
experiences trying to [ __ ] a coconut and
so for example this title is today I
[ __ ] up by not listening to it today I
[ __ ] up about it today a book about
using a coconut as a flashlight there
are so many stories about how they go
horribly wrong like for example this
dude said and he was having sex with the
coconut when he realized he's actually
allergic to coconut another one great
way to find out and this other one tried
coconutty he measured the hole wrong and
so he got his dick stuck inside so he
only measured it enough for like some
mushrooms to going and he couldn't bring
it back out that's what honey
well one big will get soft and we could
pull it out that's true yeah this other
one he was [ __ ] a coconut when his
mom walked into the room and caught on
oh my god I don't want to catch my boy
walking to Trader Joe's and accidentally
bought a pineapple and had sex with that
instead accidentally what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you the other dude tried he
tried to buck a watermelon because he
thought it would be softer except it
wasn't and he said that he ended up
straining his penis
Jahlil onslaught though he tried to bug
a watermelon but instead it slipped and
broke his toe he ended up having to go
to the emergency room what the
watermelon and alcohol and he tried to
[ __ ] a coconut trips and fell log going
down with it the other one he bent
apenas he's trying to pluck a coconut
it is endless you know what I never
tried I don't want to know actually I
shall a started it's never too late
never tried with the meat products what
did you try to commit I know yeah what
did you not much just like fabrics and
isn't that like like burn hey I couldn't
finish I was just experimenting of
course for scientific purposes and under
my journal I think I remember much your
journal no no no like in my
investigation I had a document like what
was good and what wasn't and you said it
from really had a journal yeah but every
time I'll tell you this I did feel
something and if something was guilt
I owned a flashlight and I [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out of that but every time after
that I wasn't a virgin at this time but
I knew that the first level is female
the second level is hand that their or
their mouth is female part a female part
just doing it with getting a girl to
touch you to self why then again the
second best oh yeah
and then actually I didn't think flesh
lie was as good as they market it to me
that's number three he said you [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of it I did I could have a
sit you know okay like a lodge that
[ __ ] right in between my couch
sofa and I [ __ ] it would
yeah good I need it to it kept slipping
away suppose we use your hand with
whatever I did but I was like nah you
might a sparkline I was like I need to
thrust because this is not the same so I
[ __ ] launched it in between my couch
and that's your very smart
that's really smart was it the orange
apartment yes did you fit on that job
smart those in my room okay
there was no juices involved all right
your boss that was all over the [ __ ]
stupid
works like I [ __ ] [ __ ] face doubt
about that job and the other thing was I
told my girlfriend at the time about it
and then she's like really can I see it
where we experiment was I was like I had
hands off and she was like doing this
thing and I was like damn this is kind
of different but it was still not the
best so at the end of the day I feel
like in conclusion in conclusion for a
guy nothing beats the real thing that's
the moral of the story the more of the
story dude like what you can't [ __ ]
couch you can't [ __ ] through I think
it's different for every guy though I've
heard that it just depends on how they
feel they're both I go pink really hand
and girls no I think what you're hearing
is guys on the [ __ ]
versus girls [ __ ] oh yeah yeah you're
talking yeah but hands hands versus
vagina never never never ever hope you
guys enjoyed that video but if you
didn't guess what you can directly
contribute to the articles that we
discussed just cruise out over to the
description box below click on that link
to submit your article also for the next
video rat up hey
[Music]